we have a voicemail number the number is
two one nine to david p apparently i
created a day that doesn't exist take a
listen to this silly david pakman there
is no november 31st i totally agree with
your show tonight on a tuesday and i
agree with you uh as far as the mental
retardation that the egg man thinks is
yeah politically correct it's actually
medically correct and i have to take
your side on that thank you great show
love watching it you have a good life
alright thank you you have a good life
as well that's an interesting sign off
i've never heard that before unless
you're angry with someone the only time
I've ever heard someone say have a good
life is if you plan to angrily never
speak to that person again but in any
case yes I was so flummoxed and and
fired up about my story earlier this
week about the Elector revolt that i
incorrectly referred to November 31st as
the date where I broke the elective
revolt story that is not a day that
exists I met November 30 maybe it's all
just the conspiracy and you never
actually cover the story that's right
tried to cover it up by mentioning a
date yet go look at our uploads from
November 31st and you'll see everything
it that that that I meant to tell you on
that day we have a great bonus show for
you today google says it will run
entirely on renewable energy next year a
fifteen-year-old boy has been charged
with the decapitation of a school
classmate and we're going to talk to uh
to you about five people close to Donald
Trump who have spread faking news over
the last few months remember david
pakman.com slash membership is the only
way to get instant access to the bonus
show you can use coupon code i voted 17
for a major discount off of membership
and the indiegogo crowdfunding campaign
is on please take a look at what we're
doing at david pakman.com slash donate
it's absolutely huge it's going to be
tremendous but we need your help